je sais assez agréables et désagréables
ce que vous venez de dire quand même
pourquoi il ya 3 millions d'avancement
est ce que vous pouvez démarche que je
peux finir déjà non je vous me répondez
me laissait à vous directement donjons
mais je me permets de faire en tout en
toute transparence
est ce que vous pouvez démentir que les
policiers mis en cause dans la sphère
est claire non pas d'abord dit lors de
leur procès verbal que c'était une
agression de la part de monsieur est
clair et que n'avait rien promis d'
injustifiée dans la réponse de la
déchirer pas de conséquence sur un cas
particulier côté d'angers en fait ce que
j'allais faire mais j'ai rédigé pas à
démentir ou pas démentir ya juste une
enquête en cours clairement je pense
qu'il ya eu énormément d'émotion autour
de 7,2 cette affaire là forcément
évidemment eu égard aux images et je
pense que maintenant c'est le temps de
la justice et je pense que maintenant si
on doit en parler
eh bien il faut avoir des éléments moi
j'ai pas tous les éléments je suis pas
magistrat
les collègues y en a deux qui sont en
détention ça c'est une réalité si vous
pas aussi on peut parler de ça par
contre on peut parler de la détention
des policiers vous avez où on a tous
l'air de dire que la police ils axent
justice est laxiste et que les policiers
ont une certaine impunité
mais je peux vous assurer qu'elle vise à
remporter dès la sanction qui est tombé
contre les agresseurs alors c'est pas
une sanction la détention provisoire
c'est une légère hausse une mesure
conservatoire cette reconstruction
c'est disproportionné simplement parce
que en même temps la garde des sceaux
mot disproportionnée vous avez
entièrement raison s'est dit cependant
gêné parce qu'évidemment grâce à dieu
grâce à dieu il est vivant et y en a un
qui est mort ils sont toujours en
circulation donc l'assainissement le
cialis monde entier les poches vous avez
raison je donc et moi c'est que je vous
en prie monsieur mai donc je trouve ça
disproportionnée tout simplement parce
que en même temps on a le garde des
sceaux qui sort une circulaire de
régulation de la population carcérale où
on dit il faut pas envoyer les gens en
prison sans faire de la peine
alternative
on a des policiers qui requit qui ont
toutes les garanties de représentation
qui ne vont pas mettre de la pression
sur les témoins c'est totalement faux et
évidemment qu'un contrôle judiciaire
aurait largement suffi c'est en ça que
c'est décevant c'est tout d'accord
maintenant j'ai pas d'autres éléments à
vous répondre et pour finir sur votre
premier propos madame madame est la
diffusion
image n'a pas changé la verge de
l'office monsieur sûr que c'est ce que
suri fusion des images n'a pas changé la
version de la police est pas changer la
version de la police qui va qui va
comparer justement les versions sait
aujourd'hui si on a pas du voir une
écriture n'est pas l'avis de michel est
clair qu'ils habitent tous en même temps
auquel mais non mais c'est son vrai nom
si vous avez une question à poser à
chaque mois moi je trouve que les les
éléments où les affaires récentes ont
permis des avancées faire avancer le
débat avant en fait on des cons et
mettez un minimum de critiques on était
taxée d'anti flic est donc en fait il y
avait d'un côté les pro flics de côté
les anti flics et ça et ça bloquait tout
et ça permettait pas de réfléchir
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
je pense qu'on peut tous dire qu on est
pro flics mais la question est quelle
police qu'elle tait anthologie bien le
comportement quelles sanctions
éventuelles quand il ya des manquements
à la déontologie et même à la loi parce
que c'est un délit de faire défaut et
des équipes d usage de faux en écriture
publique c'est ces temps bénis
d'attentats de l'attenté à la liberté de
circuler de quelqu'un de façon
arbitraire toutes ces choses là et c'est
peut-être ça donc il faudrait que vous
nous aidiez en tant que syndicat de
police a parlé plutôt que finalement
toujours un peu la même ancien qui
consiste à dire pas de vagues
je sais qu'ils disent à la façon les
pincettes que vous prenez pour parler de
vos collègues là ils sont je trouve
qu'elles sont un peu déplacée parce
qu'elles sont pas de la passerelle est
établi et établit faieff à vous est
avocate
non c'est pas bien sûr mais donc ce
serait bien que bon ça s'appelle se doit
très longtemps d'innocence dans leur
nature leur mais là les images mais les
imaginer ce qu elles sont choquantes
elle parle d'elle-même en même temps il
ya peut-être un contact vous chaque
concours recontextualise pour les pires
crapules
oui ou non du canton non je fais pas de
sophismes honnêtement honnêtement je
pense qu'on est on est très responsables
moi j'ai siégeant en conseil de
discipline
j'ai voté des révocations alors
actionnaire de police je vous le dise
droit dans les yeux et je pense mériter
oui mais c'est normal une amie me dit
quoi on cause des passes excusez moi je
vais pas critiquer la ligne éditoriale
me permettre le titre de l'émission
la police fait tel plan oui et au début
j'ai entendu le lancement c'était
violences policières
la grande confrontation déjà on pose le
truc comme ça je pense qu'il ya un souci
il n'y a pas de quand on est dans le
même camp moi je suis citoyen si je suis
un faux policier
le préfet